my
[Music]
the senate will come to order the
chaplain dr barry black will lead the
senate in prayer
let us pray
prince of peace
give us today your pardon
and peace pardon
the sins of our lips
the untrue and unkind
words we have spoken
pardon the sins of our minds
the ignoring of truth
and the refusal to face the facts
pardon the sins of our hearts
the pride that makes us esteem
ourselves as better than others
and unwilling to forgive
lord place your peace within us
that we may no longer be torn
by the cares of this life
as the members of this body receive your
peace
help them to live in unity
with each other we pray
in your great name
amen
please join me in reciting the pledge of
allegiance to the flag
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america
and to the republic for which it stands
one nation
under god indivisible with liberty and
justice for all
the clerk will read a communication to
the senate
washington d.c december 29 2020 to the
senate
under the provisions of rule one
paragraph three of the standing rules of
the senate i hereby appoint the
honorable deb fischer
a senator from the state of nebraska to
perform the duties of the chair signed
chuck grassley president pro tempore
under the previous order the leadership
time is reserved
the majority leader i'll suggest the
absolute quorum the clerk will call the
roll
mr alexander
madam president the majority leader i
was content that further proceeds on the
quorum call be dispensed with
without objection ash unanimous consent
that the veto message on h.r 6395
received from the house be considered as
having been read
spread and full upon the record upon the
journal
and be printed in the record without
objection i'll suggest that
the quorum clerk will call the roll mr
alexander
not a president the majority leader i
just consent to further proceedings on
the quorum call be dispensed with
without objection
congress has returned to work this week
to enact the 60th
annual national defense authorization
act
into law yesterday a bipartisan super
majority in the house
voted to reapprove the conference report
of this must pass legislation today the
senate will set up a final vote for
tomorrow
wednesday for this chamber to follow
suit soon this important legislation
will be passed
into law president trump has rightly
noted that this year's defense bill does
not contain every provision that we
republicans
would have wanted i'm confident our
democratic colleagues feel the same way
but that is the case every year and yet
for 59 consecutive years in counting
washington has put our differences aside
found common ground and passed the
annual defense bill
not once in six decades has a congress
led its differences prevented from
completing this work for our national
security and our men and women
who wear the uniform this year's ndaa
will continue our momentum in rebuilding
and modernizing
our armed forces it will authorize the
personnel
equipment tools and training we need to
reinforce
the national defense strategy and to
deter great power rivals like
china and russia it will cement our
advantage
on the seas on land in the air in cyber
space
and in space and the bill will help us
continue to recruit
retain and support the men and women who
keep us safe
it provides a pay raise for the troops
improvements for military housing child
care
and more so madam president for the
brave men and women of the united states
armed forces failure is simply not an
option
so when it's our turn in congress to
have their backs failure is not an
option
either i would urge my colleagues to
support this legislation
one more time when we vote tomorrow
now on another matter on sunday
president trump signed into law another
historic bipartisan rescue package it
will provide
major support to american families
through what we hope
will be the home stretch of our fight
with the coronavirus
congressional republicans congressional
democrats and president trump's senior
team had all worked together to pass
hundreds of billions more dollars in
urgent assistance
to the people who need it most this new
law will set up a targeted second round
of paycheck protection
to save jobs it will renew and continue
federal programs that have helped laid
off workers endure the crisis
it will send more cash to households it
will invest billions in vaccine
distribution so the success of operation
warp speed
kills the pandemic as fast as possible
and much more this bipartisan compromise
was our shot at getting help to working
families
on the urgent timeline that they need
once again i want to applaud president
trump for signing the bill and getting
this much-needed assistance
into the pipeline during this process
the president highlighted three
additional issues of national
significance which
he would like to see congress tackle
together
first as he explained the president
would like further direct financial
support for american households
second is the growing willingness on
both sides of the aisle to at least
re-examine the special legal protections
afforded to technology companies under
section 230
of the communications decency act
including the ways it benefits some of
the most
prosperous most powerful big tech
firms and the third subject since every
american regardless of their politics
should feel the integrity of our
democracies beyond reproach
is exploring further ways to protect the
sanctity of america's ballots while
continuing to respect the federal
government's limited role
in standing behind state and local
government
who actually run elections
those are the three important subjects
the president has linked together
this week the senate will begin a
process to bring these three priorities
into focus
i moved to procedure calendar number
480s3985
the clerk will report motion to proceed
to s-3985 a bill to improve and reform
policing practices accountability and
transparency
unanimous consent that following leader
remarks on wednesday december 30th
the time until 115 be equally divided
between the proponents and
opponents of the bill with the opponent
time being controlled by senator paul or
his
destiny further upon the use or yielding
back of that time the senate vote on
passage of the bill
the objections of the president to the
contrary notwithstanding
finally if passed the motion to
reconsider be considered made and laid
upon the table
with no intervening action or debate
is there objection deserving the right
to object the democratic leader
well thank you madam president now the
senate
is here this week for a rare holiday
session to address two major issues
the president's veto of the annual
defense bill
and the effort to send two thousand
dollar survival checks
to millions and millions of american
families
something senate democrats strongly
support
the senate should be in session to
address both
issues there are only a few days left in
this session
we should not adjourn until the senate
holds a vote on both
measures the ndaa veto override
and the house bill to provide two
thousand dollar checks
for the american people as we all know
the majority leader controls the
schedule on the floor
so leader mcconnell holds the key to
unlocking this dilemma the solution
is a simple one put both bills up
for a simple up or down vote and then
let the chips fall where they may i
believe both measures will pass
as they should but leader mcconnell must
allow the senate to vote on both pieces
of legislation
the defense bill and the two thousand
dollar checks
before we go home we will start the
process on overriding the president's
veto of the defense bill tomorrow
today at the end of my remarks i will
ask the senate's consent
to take up the house passed bill to
provide the american people
immediate survival checks of two
thousand dollars a person
throughout this pandemic working
americans have taken it on the chin
right now they're facing their hardest
in their darkest days
tens of millions have lost their jobs
tens of millions are struggling to put
food on the table
keep a roof over their heads in the
wealthiest nation on earth
modern dr modern day bread line stretch
for miles
down american highways the fastest way
to get money into americans pockets is
to send
some of their tax dollars right back
from where they came
two thousand dollar stimulus checks
could mean the difference between
american families having groceries
for a few extra weeks or going hungry
the difference between paying the rent
or being kicked out of your home that
you've lived in for years
it could buy precious time for tens of
millions of people
as the vaccine thankfully makes its way
across the country
of course we could have taken up this
issue weeks ago
in the covid bill congress just passed
democrats wanted generous direct
payments to the american people
speaker pelosi and i repeatedly asked
our republican counterparts
how much they could support their answer
600 it was a compromise many of us were
not happy about
i came to the floor myself
with the senator from vermont to ask
that we double at least the size of
those checks
a republican senator objected six
hundred dollars was the most
republicans would support well my
colleagues and my fellow americans six
hundred dollars
is not enough not enough from the mother
in nashville
four thousand dollars behind on the rent
whose water was shut off
earlier this month not for the medical
receptionist in macomb
twenty one hundred dollars behind on the
rent whole electricity shut off
in september on her son's third day
of virtual kindergarten not for the 12
million americans who have fallen on
average nearly six
thousand dollars behind on their rent in
their utilities
or the 26 million americans who have had
trouble putting food on the table
in the past five days six hundred
dollars nope
it's not enough so in a moment i will
move to have the senate take up the
house bill
to increase that number to two thousand
dollars
which i might add had broad bipartisan
support
i don't want to hear that we can't
afford it i don't want to hear that it
would add too much to the deficit
senate republicans added nearly 2
trillion to the deficit
to give corporations a massive tax cut
republicans just fought to include a tax
break
for three martini lunches in the covert
relief bill
so i don't want to hear it that it costs
too much to help working families get a
check when they're struggling
to keep their jobs pay their families
pay their rent
feed their families and live a halfway
normal and decent life even in our
deeply divided times madam president
this issue has united americans from
coast to coast
and bridge the massive political divide
here in washington
a vast majority of the public republican
and democrat
strongly support two thousand dollar
checks
an overwhelming bipartisan majority in
the house
supports two thousand checks senate
democrats strongly support
two thousand dollar checks even
president trump
supports two thousand dollar checks
there's one question left today do
senate republicans
join with the rest of america in
supporting
two thousand dollar checks now some of
my republican colleagues have said they
support the checks
but there's a major difference in saying
you support two thousand dollar checks
and fighting to put them into law the
house bill is the only way the only way
to deliver these stimulus checks before
the end of session
will senate republicans fight for a vote
on the house passed cash act
or will they look some other way
will senate republicans stand against
the house of representatives
the democratic majority in the senate
and the president of their own party
to prevent these two thousand dollar
checks
from going out the door we're about
to get the answers to these questions
so now mr adam
madam president i ask consent
to set the ndaa nope sorry
madam president where am i
would the senator modify his request
to include a unanimous consent request
that the senate you to include unanimous
consent
that the senate proceed to the immediate
consideration of h.r 9051
a bill received from the house to
increase recovery rebate amounts to two
thousand dollars per individual
that the bill be read a third time and
passed
the motion to reconsider be considered
made and laid upon the table
with no intervening action or debate
is there objection to the modification
object
objection is heard is there objection to
the original request
the senator from vermont thank you for
reserving
reserving the right to object
we should all be very very clear
the working class of this country today
faces more economic desperation
than at any time since the great
depression of the 1930s
and working families need help
now not next year
but right now last night
the house of representatives with a
two-thirds majority 275-134
two-thirds bipartisan
vote moved to increase the direct
payment
going to working families from six
hundred dollars
per adult to two thousand dollars
per adult the house did the right thing
i congratulate them and now it is time
for the senate to step up to the plate
and do what the working families of this
country overwhelmingly
want us to do
adam president is a result of the
pandemic
tens of millions of americans have lost
their jobs and their incomes
these families in the middle of the
winter
now face the threat of eviction
and the possibility of being thrown out
in the streets
hunger in america is
at the highest level that it has been
for decades with moms and dads
struggling to feed their kids
and working families lining up
mile after mile to get emergency
food packages we are even seeing
an increase in grocery store
shoplifting as desperate americans
try to keep their families from going
hungry all of this taking place
in the wealthiest country in the history
of the world
madam president over the last number of
years as i think everybody in america
knows
congress has provided massive tax breaks
for the very wealthiest people in our
country
which is one of the reasons why today we
have more income in wealth
inequality than any time since the 1920s
in fact in the midst of this pandemic
this terrible pandemic
inequality has grown worse
with many in the billionaire class
seeing their wealth
increase by hundreds of billions of
dollars
while average americans struggle to put
food on the table
congress has given huge tax breaks to
large corporations
so that some of the most profitable and
largest corporations in america
today pay zero in federal income taxes
we have just passed the largest military
budget
in the history of our country 740
billion dollars
more than the next 10 nations combined
and by the way there was almost no
debate
about the size of that huge budget
trump's veto dealt with other issues
meanwhile over half a million americans
are homeless
half of our working families are
struggling to survive
paycheck to paycheck and in the midst of
this terrible
unprecedented pandemic over 90
million americans are uninsured or
underinsured in the midst of a pandemic
and they're not sure whether they can
afford to go to a doctor
madam president we are coming to the
close
of one of the most terrible and painful
years
in american history that is a tragic
fact
over 330 000 of our people have died
from covert 19 and as we speak
we are seeing record-breaking numbers of
new cases
and hospitals around the country being
overwhelmed
with new admissions during the last year
the education and well-being of tens of
millions of our young people
from child care to graduate school
has been disrupted and the terrible
emotional isolation that this pandemic
has caused
where people are unable to spend time
with their family or their friends
has resulted in a huge increase in
mental illness
drug addiction and even suicide
and president as i mentioned the house
has done the right thing
by an overwhelming vote democrats
and republicans voted to increase that
six hundred dollar direct payment
to two thousand dollars recent poll came
out
78 percent of the american people think
that was
the right decision they're hurting they
want
help the leaders of our country
president trump
president-elect biden minority leader
chuck schumer
the speaker of the house nancy pelosi
are all
in agreement we have got to raise that
direct
payment to 2 000
so that is where we are right now in
this historic moment
do we turn our backs on struggling
working families
or do we respond to their pain
so madam president would the
senator modify his request
that immediately following the vote on
the veto override
the senate proceed to the consideration
of h.r
9051 that the bill be considered read
a third time and the senate vote on
passage of the bill
without intervening action or debate
further that if passed the motion to
reconsider be considered made and laid
upon the table
is there objection to the request for
modification
object objection is heard
is there objection to the original i
object
objection is heard under the previous
order the senate will be in a period of
morning business
with senators permitted to speak therein
for up to 10 minutes each
i'm sorry
thank you madam president madam
president
this is our historic moment we can see
the suffering
across our country we can see how
desperate people are
we can see how during this holiday
season that people are looking at the
prospects
in the words of tony fauci
where the worst may be ahead of us for
these families the worst
may yet to have been actually
inflicted upon families in our country
and yet the republicans are refusing
to allow for a vote on giving
each individual two thousand dollars
in order to make it through the rest of
this pandemic and
senator sanders today speaks
for the millions of americans who are
suffering through
a devastating health crisis an
unemployment crisis
an eviction crisis a hunger crisis
and a crisis of faith
faith that their leaders
in this country will stand up and
provide for americans in their
hour of need meanwhile
we here in washington we must confront a
moral
crisis why can't we
keep working families from starving
even as we stand ready to approve
a massive defense bill
that's why i'm here with my colleague
bernie sanders
to call for a simple vote to provide
two thousand dollars in direct cash
payments to americans
across our country it's this simple
just like they did in the house of
representatives
the senate should have a vote up or down
yes or no
on providing these increased cash
payments
to desperate americans we can get this
done quickly and before the holiday
if leader mcconnell will simply agree
to do it they already had this vote
in the house 46 republicans voted
for it give the republicans
in the senate the same opportunity to
vote we already know
that many of them have already said they
will vote
for the two thousand dollars if they get
a chance
to vote it's this simple
we can do this because a simple
vote will just say that you want to
provide
a grand total of two thousand dollars to
americans
who need it to pay the rent to keep the
electricity on
to buy diapers to pay for life-saving
medication just to survive
this devastating pandemic
44 house republicans voted for the two
thousand dollar checks
i believe that republicans in this
chamber will do so
as well and president trump has already
made it very clear
he will sign that bill
so we can see where the opposition is
it's the leadership of the republicans
in the united states senate
people across our country are falling
ill
and falling behind on their bills and
for the families of the hundreds of
thousands who have died
in the coronavirus medical and funeral
funeral expenses are compounding
their grief they need money in
their pockets in massachusetts
this past sunday we hit a hundred deaths
in a single day
the highest death toll our state has
seen
in a 24 hour period since the very
beginning of this pandemic
in the week before christmas twenty one
thousand new people in our state applied
for unemployment benefits
just as donald trump let these
protections lapse before millions
of americans were losing
their benefits and that is a tragedy
a two thousand dollar check is the most
direct and effective mechanism for
delivering economic relief right now to
those barely holding
on throughout this crisis particularly
low-income americans
immigrant communities our gig our
service workers our essential workers
they need help they have been helping
our families we need to help their
families and right now these checks
would help
158 million people across our country
pay for housing put food on the table
make sure that grandma and grandpa have
their diabetes
or heart medication that's why
senator sanders senator kamala harris
and i introduced legislation
to provide every person in our country
regardless
of immigration status with two thousand
dollar monthly recurring payments
to help weather this storm we knew then
seven months ago that a single twelve
hundred dollar relief check was not
going to be
enough to help families get by and the
600
payment in the latest coronavirus
package is crumbs
to working people who have faced
economic hardship
through no fault of their own it won't
even cover a month
of rent let alone heating bills food
bills
wi-fi bills for students learning from
home and all the other expenses
which are piling up for these families
now some
of my republican colleagues have said
that providing two thousand dollars
would be too expensive well
here are some other costs they seem to
have forgotten
if our proposal to increase stimulus
checks to two thousand dollars is signed
the overall cost of the stimulus bill
would go from nine hundred billion
dollars to one
point three six trillion dollars yes
that is 464 billion dollar increase
over what we were currently projecting
for this bill
but it is only a fraction
of the 740 billion dollar defense bill
that this chamber stands ready to
approve again
this week my republican colleagues
and i hate to say this but my republican
colleagues
seem more interested in funding defense
than in funding the defenseless and
that's what this debate
is all about what do we do to help
these defenseless families
in this moment of national crisis we are
able to afford spending three-quarters
of a trillion dollars on a bloated
defense budget
spending that is supposed to protect our
country yet did
nothing to inoculate against the most
profound public health emergency in a
century
but we can't give hungry and suffering
americans
two thousand dollars that
is a moral failure for
our country give americans
this money
most of my colleagues support this
defense budget
they got to vote on it a few weeks ago
and i know they stand ready to override
president
trump's racist belligerent veto
we're here today asking the same thing
for two thousand dollar payments
a simple up or down vote let's bring the
house bill up for a vote
leader schumer is committed to bring it
forward
we can get this done before the holiday
we can do this for americans before the
year
is out we must remember that what makes
america the envy of the world is not
simply the strength of our defense and
military
but the strength of our people
people like ahmed jaya
a parent of three who was laid off from
his job as a doorman
at the omni parker house in boston this
past march
ahmed receives 400 dollars a week in
unemployment benefits
but it is not enough to cover the bills
to keep rolling in
as he now faces expiring health coverage
as well of people like tanya destefano
from spencer massachusetts who gave
birth to a beautiful baby boy on
halloween and returned from the hospital
to find an eviction notice taped
to the front of her door
these are the stories that should be
driving our fights
these are the people who need relief now
and these checks
will go right back into our economy
because people will spend this money
they need it for the necessities
which are confronting their families
right now last week
donald trump used these people as
political pawns
he stalled signing the coronavirus
relief package
claiming that he wants to give two
thousand dollar checks to every american
by delaying president trump
may have stiffed unemployed americans
out of 300 dollars this week in
unemployment benefits
benefits that they will not get back
so let's now hold donald trump to his
word
let's bring this to a vote and let's
pass two thousand dollar relief checks
for every person in our country
and put that bill on donald trump's desk
this pandemic has laid bare the tragedy
of two americas
one in which billionaires grew their
wealth by 931 billion dollars over the
course
of this pandemic an america where the
rich
continue to get richer and the other
america
that has seen unprecedented economic
uncertainty
great depression level unemployment
rates and devastating losses
where black and latinx workers suffer
disproportionately higher rates of
unemployment
and their families suffer higher rates
of coronavirus infection
and death where workers get laid off
while ceos get raises
and companies engage in stock buyback
plans
where residents get evicted are their
electricity shut off but major
corporations barely
pay taxes for those workers and families
and struggling households in america for
the vast majority of america
two thousand dollars is a lifeline and
it is time for
leader mcconnell to bring this
legislation
to the floor for a vote the american
people
have a right to know where every member
of the senate stands
on this issue they now know where
president trump says he stands
they now know where every member of the
united states house of representatives
stands
and the american people have a right to
know in this desperate time that we are
living through
who was on their side
to give their families the help which
they needed
senator sanders is right we should have
a vote
it should be yes or no and we should do
this before
the end of this year madam president
i yield back the balance and president
the senator from connecticut thank you
madam president
madam president america has
600 billionaires
now a billion dollars doesn't sound like
a lot of money these days
president trump just signed a bill
begrudgingly that
has 900 billion dollars in it but trust
me
a billion dollars is still a whole lot
of money it's actually so much money
that it's
really hard to find words to describe
what it looks like but let me try
if you're for instance one of the half a
million americans who makes the minimum
wage
in this nation and you're lucky enough
to work
40 hours a week guess how many years
you would have to work in order to
get a billion dollars 500 years
a thousand years 10 000 years no you're
not even close
if you make minimum wage in america
today
you would need to work for 75
000 years in order to make a billion
dollars
75 000 years neanderthals
were roaming the earth 75 000
years ago those guys if they made
minimum wage would have to work
up until present day every single day
and that is of course if they didn't
spend a dime of the money they made
in order to accrue a billion dollars
a billion dollars is a bananas
amount of money and there are 600 people
in america today who make at least that
amount of money or have that amount of
money to their name that's crazy
with a billion dollars you are leading a
life
that frankly none of us can really
imagine
right you've got private planes you've
got yachts you've got
household staffs in the dozens you've
got enough money to make sure that your
children and your
grandchildren and your great
grandchildren and your great great
grandchildren
never have to work a day of their lives
generations of your offspring
can just live lives of indolent luxury
without a care if they so choose
you know where i was two days before
thanksgiving this year
i was at hampden middle school in my
state
to help hand out free food
for the unemployed the poor and the
disabled ahead of a long
holiday weekend those long weekends can
be
really hard especially the ones that
fall at the end of the month
when the snap benefits have long run out
i got there as darkness fell but right
at the beginning
of the event and i noticed that
down the hill from the roundabout at the
school where they were handing out the
food there was a
usually empty parking lot and that night
at that moment at the beginning of the
event that parking lot was
lit up by hundreds of sets of headlights
hundreds of cars just sitting there
idling
in that parking lot i asked the
organizer of the event what was going on
in that parking lot was that some other
event happening
that evening why all the cars
he told me the cars started pulling into
that lot
hours ago they got wind we were handing
out
food and they got here early to make
sure
that they didn't get left out we have
enough food for 300 people
and there were 300 cars in that lot
before i even got here
that is what has happened during this
pandemic
millions of families all across this
nation through no fault of their own
have lost
their jobs have had their hours
dramatically cut back
they had no savings because work doesn't
pay in this country anymore they spent
everything they earned each month and so
when the economy collapsed virtually
overnight in the spring
they got desperate really fast
and i want you to think about
what it's really like on an
hour-to-hour basis when you don't have
enough
money for food for your family
the decisions you have to make
every single day are practically
animalistic
do you make your kids go hungry during
the day
when they need the most energy
or do you skimp on dinner and force your
kids to go to bed
with hunger pangs there are hundreds
of thousands of mothers and fathers who
right now
as i am speaking are making that
decision today
that's the reality of this pandemic
but here's another reality those
600 billionaires in this country
as it turns out as a group they lost
nothing nothing during this pandemic
no exactly the opposite they got richer
the wealthiest 600 americans
collectively added 1
trillion dollars to their bank accounts
let me say it again
the richest 600 americans gained
a trillion dollars over the course of
2020
and let's be clear that's not money that
grew
in their money tree orchards yeah we're
printing some more money these days but
wealth isn't far away from a zero-sum
game still and so when we allow for 600
people
in the country to control 50 percent of
the nation's wealth
that's coming out of your pocket
600 people in a country of 328 million
isn't a lot of people but you know
what's a smaller number
than 600 52.
there are 52 republicans in this chamber
52 people who are going to have a
decision
to make about what to do in a country
where
millions are literally starving as we
speak
well six hundred billionaires count the
one
trillion dollars in additional wealth
that they have accumulated
during this period of national calamity
the question before these 52 senate
republicans
is simple it's simple
should we give two thousand dollars to
low and middle income americans right
now to help them
survive this crisis that's the decision
senate republicans
have to make right now time is running
out
600 billionaires got a trillion dollars
richer this year and the question before
senate republicans
is this are you willing to spend
an amount equal to just half
of that windfall to america's
billionaires in order to help
160 million americans
because right now the 52
senate republicans serving in this
chamber are the only thing
standing in the way of two thousand
dollars being sent
to 160 million of our neediest citizens
the house passed the bill authorizing
the checks
in a big bipartisan vote it is hard to
get two-thirds of the house of
representatives to agree on what
time it is but two-thirds of the house
of representatives
voted for the two thousand dollar checks
president trump supports the two
thousand dollar checks
so he'll sign the bill if the senate
sends it to him
we can vote on the house bill today
like in a matter of hours if senate
republicans agree
so why isn't this happening
why didn't senator mcconnell announce
the schedule for the vote on the two
thousand dollar
checks bill why didn't he agree to
senator schumer's
request to bring it up for an immediate
vote
now a lot of republicans are saying they
object to the payments because it costs
too much
and it's going to add too much to the
deficit well frankly
spare me the fake righteous indignation
about the deficit all of a sudden
three years ago these same deficit hawk
republicans passed a tax cut bill
that before the pandemic hit had already
added over
200 billion dollars to the annual
deficit
and that was a tax cut where eighty
percent of the benefits went to the
richest
one percent of americans warren buffett
wrote in his note to investors last year
that the deficit finance tax cuts earned
his empire 29
billion dollars overnight that windfall
buffett noted quote did not come from
anything we accomplished
at berkshire so it's funny deficits just
didn't matter to the 52 when it was tax
cuts
to the 600 richest people in america
but even if this congress wasn't ending
in five days
and we had time to figure out how to pay
for it you know how we can't pay for
it cutting foreign aid
president trump has been talking a lot
about foreign aid in the last week
now the money we spend on foreign aid
all supported by democrats and
republicans over the years
all of its smart investments in our
nation's security that actually wasn't
in the covid relief package it was in
the annual budget as it always is
it just so happens that this year the
coveted relief package and the annual
budget were passed
together but just for argument's sake
let's say trump got his way and every
single dollar
of foreign aid was cut out of the budget
would that pay for the two thousand
dollar checks
not even close president trump
apparently
has an oversized impression of how much
money we spend on foreign aid
because our annual foreign aid spending
doesn't even equal ten
percent of the cost of a one-time two
thousand dollar payment to low and
middle
income citizens there is also some
speculation that senator mcconnell is
going to
join together the two thousand dollar
payments with
other much more controversial measures
much more complicated measures like
the reform of our internet liability
laws that is
an invitation for
this entire effort to fall apart
the house is finished voting they have
passed the two thousand dollar
payment bill and sent it to us they are
not interested in taking up
anything else if we start adding poison
pills to the two thousand dollar
payment bill that is just another way of
telling the american people
that this body doesn't support two
thousand dollar payments
listen being a billionaire must be crazy
i make a lot of money as a senator but
even i would have to work
7 500 years
before my earnings equaled a billion
dollars
you know what was happening 7 500 years
ago the stone age
there isn't a good reason
to oppose giving americans who aren't
billionaires a measly two thousand
dollar
check to help them put food
on the table for their kids in the
middle of this once in a lifetime
crisis there isn't a good reason
to choose to make moms and dads all
across this country
decide which two meals they'll feed
their kids
each day because three meals is not
an option two thousand dollars
doesn't put dinner on the table every
night
but man going to bed hungry when you're
11
it sucks and even dealing with it every
other night
instead of every single night
no kid is going to turn that down
there are 52 of you in the next 24 to 48
hours
you get to decide do you protect the
billionaires
or do you choose to feed that 11 year
old kid
the only thing that stands between the
american people
and a 2 000 emergency survival
check is 52 senate republicans
you got it understand
there's a bill pending right now
before the senate that gives two
thousand dollars
to ordinary americans yes
it costs a lot of money and maybe down
the line we'll have to ask the
billionaires to pay for it but the bills
here
right now the legislative session
expires
in five days
president trump says he'll sign it and
all that matters right now is what
these 52 people decide
the house passed the bill with lots of
democratic
and republican support the president
supports the idea
the only thing that can stop two
thousand dollar
payments to struggling americans right
now is
52 senate republicans some things
in washington aren't that simple but
this is
i yield the floor
with the absence of quorum look we'll
call the roll
mr alexander
madam president
the senator from texas is recognized
madam president asked that the quorum
call be dispensed with without objection
madam president we didn't expect to be
in session uh
this week but we are and of course
as we all know the theme for this entire
year has been covered 19
writ large more than 30
30 000 americans have died from the
corona of
novel coronavirus tens of millions have
lost their jobs in every community
across the country
has felt the devastating blow dealt by
this pandemic
but as we know the threats that existed
long before this virus still are with us
even though most of the world hit pause
to battle coven 19
our adversaries did not and our brave
service members didn't pack their bags
and not show up for work when everybody
else shut down
over the last several months as the
senate has worked to support
our country through this pandemic we've
kept an
eagle eye on the other threats on the
horizon
and we passed the national defense
authorization act to ensure that we are
prepared
for whatever comes at us for our forces
to continue fighting and defeating
our adversaries in every corner of the
world they need funding
they need stability they need to be able
to plan
and they need the unwavering support of
the united states
congress and all 330 million americans
the 2021 ndaa provides that support from
congress
it will prepare our military and service
members to address the threats that
exist today
while preparing for those that will we
will inevitably face tomorrow
earlier this month this legislation
passed the house by a vote of 335 to 78
and the senate by a vote of 84-13
those are rare vote margins in congress
these days
and that alone is a testament to the
importance
of this legislation and its bipartisan
support
we know the president has a
constitutional authority to veto
any bill for virtually any reason
and he has exercised that power with
this legislation
the reasons the president has given i
don't think are frivolous at all
that they just shouldn't be tagged to
this particular piece of legislation his
concerns
about section 230 and the under the
communications decency act and the power
of these
social media platforms to censor speech
is troubling indeed this is something we
really haven't confronted before we know
that
under the first amendment the government
can't censor speech
but with small town newspapers and media
outlets and other alternatives
fading to this away more and more the
american people rely on facebook
and google and other internet platforms
to get their information
and they have i believe become de facto
public
forum so i agree that we do need to
address
section 230 of the communications
decency act as the president
has pointed out the president also has a
point
about the commission to rename military
bases that's part of the
defense authorization act unfortunately
the amendment that was adopted in the
armed services committee
undermines the role of congress once the
commission makes its report
to do as congress believes should be
done
but the truth is as we've learned from
our
friends across the pond in the uk no
parliament
can bind a future parliament and indeed
no
congress combined a future congress
that's true
so if these are things that the
president believes we should address
and that members of of the congress and
the new administration believe we should
address we will address them
and we have an opportunity to do that
but we should not try to do that on this
bill
and risk the loss of this important
piece of legislation now in its 60th
year
of adoption the defense
department hands down the largest is as
hands down the largest employer in the
united states with nearly 2.9 million
employees including both service members
and civilians
these men and women can be found in more
than 160 countries around the world and
on
all seven continents supporting them
is a herculean task and the ndaa
is a significant way in which we do that
the defense authorization bill also
includes a three percent pay raise for
our troops
and additional support for their
families
such as career support for military
spouses and quality child care
on military bases given the fact we have
an all-volunteer military it's important
we not only
support our service members who wear the
uniform but the families that support
them
as well i've heard it said you can
recruit a member of the united states
military but if you want to retain them
you've got to take care of their family
and i believe that's absolutely true
this bill also ensures previous reforms
to improve the quality of military
housing and health care are implemented
appropriately those who serve in our
military have made tremendous sacrifices
in order to safeguard
our freedoms and our way of life i
regard our support for them
and for our national defense the number
one priority of the federal government
everything else pales and significance
so we should do everything in our power
to ensure that they and their families
are appropriately taken care of beyond
pay and benefits that means giving
them the military members the training
the facilities the equipment they need
not only to succeed
on the job but to return home safely
the ndaa authorizes military
construction
projects across the country including
183 million
dollars in texas which will bring
serious updates and improvements
to our military bases at joint base san
antonio
this funding will provide for a range of
new facilities including a barracks
a flight simulation system and an f-16
mission training center
at joint reserve base fort worth it will
support an f-35
operations and maintenance facility
vehicle maintenance shop and an aircraft
maintenance hangar
it will also support fuel facilities at
fort hood
and provide additional funding for the
pantex plant
in amarillo which maintains a large
portion of our nuclear
stockpile
maintained and modernized facilities are
a critical component to military
readiness
and this legislation makes tremendous
investments in our facilities
around the world it will authorize 93
new f-35 joint strike fighters
that will be built by texans in fort
worth
as we work to counter increasingly
sophisticated adversaries around the
world this investment in our military
readiness
could not be more important in addition
to supporting
our our members in uniform and ensuring
they're ready for action when called
upon
the ndaa helps our military take stock
of the evolving threat landscape
and ensure that our country is taking
active steps to counter threats
on the horizon in recent years china and
russia
have risen to the top of the threats
to our world through our country and to
world order
with china now assuming the number one
role
we done we remember the cold war after
world war
ii where we've sought to contain
encounter
expansionism and actually the mutual
deterrence that we've established during
that time has worked
but china is a unique challenge
and none of the old rules apply
to china they're increasingly
belligerent
and well-resourced and continue to
demonstrate a lack of respect not only
for the us and our closest allies but
for basic human rights
the chinese government continues its
disturbing and unacceptable genocide
against the uyghur
people the so-called political
re-education camps are nothing more
than concentration camps where uyghurs
are tortured
recent reporting has found that the
treatment in these camps often
includes forced abortions birth control
and sterilization
and china continues to chip away at the
freedoms and autonomy of hong kong
notwithstanding its promises to the
contrary using a so-called national
security law
to extinguish opposition to the chinese
communist party
and to deny the people of hong kong the
freedoms that they were promised
as i mentioned though china doesn't
stand alone as a threat
to the world russia has become
increasingly aggressive
around the world and its efforts to reap
chaos and so discord
since their attempts to interfere with
the 2016
election we've witnessed aggression
after aggression from russia
not just here in the cyberspace but
around the world
from russian-backed mercenaries fighting
in the middle east
to its attempt to steal the corona
virus vaccine research and in the last
few weeks
a massive cyber attack on u.s government
agencies
russia continues to undermine the u.s
and our allies and shows no
signs of stopping it's become
increasingly clear
if it wasn't already that china and
russia adhere to no rules
and no principles but their own
as the national defense strategy
outlined the threats posed by these two
countries
are increasingly dangerous and counting
these growing threats requires a clear
and concentrated effort from congress
that's exactly why passing the ndaa the
national defense authorization act is so
important
this legislation prioritizes strategic
competition
with china and russia and takes a strong
approach to counter the threats
posed by adversaries around the world
it will build on the progress we've made
in recent years to strengthen
our military after the draconian cuts
during the obama biden administration
and achieve
peace through strength
over the last several decades the ndaa
has provided an
annual opportunity for us to take stock
of the evolving threat landscape and
ensure that our national defense is
prepared to meet the challenges
not only of today but of tomorrow and
this year's
defense authorization act is no
exception
it takes a strong approach to counter
the threats posed by our adversaries
around the world
it invests in modernized national
defense that's critical to maintaining
peace through strength
and it provides support for our service
members and their families
and above all it sends a message to the
world that our country
is and will remain the global
military leader i've supported this
legislation on the senate floor many
times
and i'll do so once again when the
opportunity to vote
to override the veto presents itself
one of the of congress's most critical
responsibilities is to provide for the
common defense
and the ndaa the national defense
authorization act
is how we will deliver
madam president i yield the floor then
i'd note the opposite for quorum
the clerk will call the roll
mr alexander
madam president the senator from
oklahoma
and appreciation for the senate armed
services
with that objection thank you madam
president
i am i was
disappointed last week when
president trump vetoed the ndaa
this bill has been out there this will
be the 60th year that we've had
the ndaa the ndaa is the national
defense
authorization act and i've said so many
times
countless times on the floor of the
house and the floor of the senate that
this is the most important
bill that we have some people don't
agree with that but i do uh that's what
we're supposed to be doing here we're
supposed to be defending america
and there's a lot we're in the most
threatened situation we've ever been in
i i sometimes look back and think of the
the good old days of the cold war
when he had two superpowers out there
and we knew what they had they knew what
we had
they uh mutual sure destruction meant
something at that time
you know you kill us we kill you and
everyone's happy it's uh
but that those are that's living in the
past but
anymore now with the weaponry that's out
there
you can get one outside group that
doesn't have any resources at all
and they have the ability to wipe out
another
country countries so it's it's a real
threat that we're up against i do
chair the committee called the senate
armed services committee and uh
i uh uh of course i've been very active
in the national defense authorization
act every year
since um well since 1987.
it's a long time so uh i'm proud of the
conference report that we had the ndaa
right here
our vote in this senate was to 13.
wow that's uh you you can't find that
kind of uh
togetherness in in in a cause any
anywhere else
but it puts members of the family
of the of the of the military
first and i i share the the president
trump's frustration about section 230
and i know that
it's a complicated thing the majority of
people in america don't know what that's
all about
but section 230 is something that has
nothing to do with the military
nothing at all the committee that i
chair is the armed services committee
that would be found
in the jurisdiction of the judiciary
committee the judiciary committee
is chaired by senator lindsey graham he
does a great job
sharing that that's where the any kind
of reform
in section 230 should come from
and i agree that the president should
have the authority to determine troop
levels
that's what we have in this bill we have
we we have the truth the the president
making those decisions
that's why we made sure that the final
ndia gave the
the president very broad authority in
determining
troop levels uh all around and we've
we've looked at them in
in western europe in eastern europe
we've looked in
ethiopia in afghanistan and other
places around around the world and um
and and so we look at what we've done
and i was going to mention i've been
down here several times talking about
the
the the president what he has done and
what he has done
the the great job that he's done for the
united states
and i'm going to wind up some comments
on
on on a card that i put together i put
this card together
back in uh two years ago
talking about the top top ten trump
accomplishments and i think it's
important that people remember that
now you're going to get a lot of people
down here forgetting about all the
really good things that have happened
but and so i'm going to talk about that
in a minute but
i'm here today because we have to pass
the ndaa
this would be the 60th year in the row
that we
that we have the ndaa and it's necessary
to have it's the most important bill of
the year i
believe this for a long time you've
heard me say it before
i always stand with our troops here a
few of the military service members and
their families will
suffer if we if we don't enact it for
the 60th year
if the ndaa is not passed more than 200
000 military families will see
smaller paychecks in january because the
special
pays and the bonuses for hazard pay are
all
part of this this uh this uh this bill
additionally it would hurt the areas
where the military is having this
most serious problem in a way it's kind
of a misbag
mixed bag because we have
prior to the pandemic coming along and
that was in
in about march of last year uh
before that happened we had the best
economy i could argue that we've had in
my lifetime
and and uh all these things were very
very good and then of course
when that happened everything changed
now one of the problems you have when
you have such a great economy
is that you have a lot of competition
you know we have we have to have a
military force
that military force has to have
resources that have to have the ability
to
to uh to step in because we don't know
where the threat next threat's going to
come from
and this would with people with special
abilities and i'm talking about pilots
and cyber experts and engineers
and doctors that's where we have a
problem you know we don't
we don't have enough of them pilots i've
been an
active pilot now for longer than most
members here have been alive
and uh and and i i
know that back during the previous
administration the obama administration
we had a very serious problem because we
were not able to attract
the pilots at that time and uh
and because that was when we had a
president
who and he's not he wasn't ashamed of it
his top priority is not defending
america that wasn't
what he he had other priorities and so
consequently we went through
a period of the last five years the last
five years of his administration were
the the year uh 2010 through 2015
and during that time frame he reduced
the funding for the military by
25 the same time he did that
china was increasing theirs in that same
time frame by 83
so we have china increasing their
military expenditures
by 83 at the same time we're reducing
ours by
25 and so we had serious problems there
and and uh one of the areas where when
people are cutting the military
that are the that they do it won't be as
noticeable
was in uh the flying hours so we had
pilots out there
but they weren't flying the hours that
they needed to fly to keep their
proficiency up and consequently a lot of
them left and went to their lines and
went other places because
uh we were
they they were wanting to be flying the
hours and that's
one of the things the problems that we
had during that time
so we have the the military's ability to
recruit and retain
service members that are in the shortest
supply and as i mentioned that would be
things like
like cyber experts and engineers and
doctors
so they have the skill sets that need to
be
done out there and and uh and of course
this president came along and we started
rebuilding the military i
always remember being at the white house
during a time that we were
we were talking about what we're going
to do with the military and he actually
looked over at me and he said what do
you think we need to do
with the military i said it's going to
have to be we have to rebuild the
military
it's going to cost something like 700
billion
750 billion dollars before it's over he
said that's what we should do we need to
start with that
and this president with his leadership
took us
with a new priority in in defending
america and building our military and it
happened
so we have the uh things that will
happen that if we don't pass this thing
the the education of children for
military families
there's a thing called the impact aid
impact aid comes about
when we don't have the you you don't get
the tax base
increase with the added enrollment into
the schools
the children of military families so
they have impact because they don't pay
the
the taxes so the impact aid is the
amount of money that
it supplements that to all of these not
just in my state of oklahoma but
throughout the
uh throughout the country it ensures
that children of military families
receive a quality education by
supplementing the school
districts the budgets where they're
required if the nda's not passed
military construction projects you know
i have
one in my state of oklahoma that is is
one that would
let's see where where is that yeah we we
have a thing
where we we uh uh
have an ammunition depot a demolition
shop
for one and this is something where
we've gone through a lot of backgrounds
base realignment and closure commissions
and we have
increased the size of our ammunition
demolition
activities substantially and we're doing
most of it now
right there in oklahoma well this has a
new
demolition shop in there so we can get
rid of a lot of these things we
were not able to uh to get rid of
so we have military construction
projects in 38 states
and one happens to be in the state of
maine it's uh it's
very significant that they be able to do
these projects
if the the military constructions don't
happen
both and authorization and appropriation
people don't understand this because
it's kind of
talk around but in order for something
to get done you have to have
authorized that's what the committee
that i chair
does authorize a military project then
he has to be appropriated and the
appropriators come along
and they put the money in there and
that's what uh that's how this
system works so the nda if it's not
passed the military won't be able to
increase the end strength
or the total number of troops and
military services
that's where they're needed to address
the growing threats
and strengths increases if it doesn't
happen without
authorization you can't you can't
appropriate it so the ndaa
if it should not be be passed the
pentagon loses the ability to quickly
and efficiently process security
clearance
uh investigations right now it's there's
a backlog
because it takes a long time to do this
but this has
a streamlining lighting provision in it
that's going to make that
a lot easier so we'll be able to get
security clearances
all these things are tied into this
into this bill the od
if we didn't pass this thing would would
lack the authority to pay the
non-military personnel
on hospital ships they're the ones who
are doing the great job right now with
the
with the coven covet response and that's
just kind of a snapshot
of what we're counting on to support our
troops in the field
the bare minimum we need without the
ndaa we lose
all of that and also lose all of
the other policies right now
is uh this bill makes
china the the the primary
strategic threat i think we all
understand that
we have uh strategic threats from russia
and china
uh last year we had the the european
part uh address this year the bill
is pending right now that we're going to
try to get past for this year
and i think we will successfully do that
but we're going to that's going to be
concentrating on the pacific area that's
china
and the things that china is doing that
people don't uh
many people don't realize the threat
that's out there right now we're up
as i understand it to seven different uh
areas where we they the chinese
are actually building creating islands
in the in the south china sea
now this is something that's different
than it's ever been done before
i contend i've always continued it's
illegal but they're still doing it
they're doing it and and that's what
they are the the effort that they're
making there and if you if you go into
these islands where they're rebuilding
it's almost as if china is preparing for
world war three
all of them are in this this is what is
happening right now the uh right now we
know about the
solar winds hack the hack that we're
facing
that's something where we have language
to deal with that in the defense
authorization bill
the new hunt forward authority that
allows
our cyber operators to do more work to
find
malicious actors proactively and this is
something that we need to get done
for the safety for the defense of our
country
it implements the cyber solarium
commission in the recommendations there
are 27 recommendations that they have
in this uh this commission and
establishes a new national
cyber director um you know these are
things where
it's a moving target there's a lot of
things that we're doing now that we
should have been doing before
and it took china and russia to kind of
forge ahead of us
as they did in the previous
administration to
to remind us that we have these very
serious problems
so our troops need the ndaa
and it's our responsibility to make sure
that they have the equipment and the
training the resources
to complete the mission and return home
safely i'll i'll close with this
one reminder on december the 29th
1777 243
years ago today general george
washington wrote
to the continental congress imploring
that they
need to provide the resources his troops
needed he wrote
and this is a quote from that he said i
hope that the supplies
they will be able to furnish in aid of
those which congress may immediately
import themselves will be equal
incompetent
to every demand if they do not i fear
i am satisfied the troops will never
be in a situation to answer the public
expectation
and perform the duties required of them
you know that's just true today as it
was in 1777
so we've got to do that we look at the
national security
winds of this president i i think people
don't talk about that
as much we have identified china as the
number one adversary
that was in the in the nds that's a
national defense
survey it's it was put together
by 12 of the real experts six
republicans six
democrats it's been the blueprint for
our military
ever since that time this is about three
years ago
and this is what we and they identified
china as the major threat
two and a half trillion
dollars to rebuild the military and
that's what
we were able to get done increase the
size of the military
replace the obsolete equipment new
investments in future tech
hypersonics is a good example both
hypersonics both
russia and china are ahead of us in that
area
of hypersonics it's a new state of the
art
the pay raise for the for the kids it
took out the terrorist leaders
yeah how many people remember that
baghdadi and
solimani they were the the top
terrorists in the world
they're gone now this president this
administration took care of that
established the space force you know the
first
when the space force that was the first
new
force that was established uh in in many
many years
i wasn't real sold on it at first
because i thought we were doing a pretty
good job
but it wasn't coordinated it was you had
the
different military units doing it and
they weren't really even talking to each
other
so that is that's what we put together
there's this president that
provided the leadership in doing that
the widow's tax everybody remembers that
that was something that had to be done
and we did it others talked about it
this president did it the the the isis
caliphate
is destroyed the abraham accords
the supported israel through the
security assistance and
we know that that's going on it's going
on today
all these things this president has done
and has done
a a great job but i do want to mention
and i think it's worthwhile doing
because it's um
we know what's gonna what won't happen
if we don't
if we don't pass this bill we won't get
the bonuses necessary i already
mentioned that
impact aid mentioned that military
construction project or authorizations
we would not have that the full pay for
dod civilians
that has to be done but that was and
that's been
been talked about by a lot of
administrations but not really done
and then i've finalized this by talking
about
the uh china i mean this bill
supports or helps china
nothing in the bill helps china in any
way at all
there's a group called the american
enterprise institute uh there that's a
group it's kind of the
conservative conscience of uh uh
the the evaluates programs that come
along
they they said and this is a quote they
said this bill has the most substantial
and consequential china-related
provisions
since the 2000 ndaa
now they're talking about this bill what
it does for china
establishes the pacific deterrence well
we talked about the european deterrence
last year in the nba
bill this is the pacific deterrence
that's china that we're talking about
it shifts it shifts the supply chains
away from china in semiconductors
printed circuit circuit boards
uh pharma pharmaceuticals
and it stimulates the economies in in
those ways
it brings chinese malign national
security activities
into light so we know what they're doing
who the good guys are and the bad guys
are
this supports taiwan you know we've been
doing that for a long period of time
this bill accelerates that program
prevents china's
intellectual property threat and i have
a whole list here that i'd
asked unanimous consent be inserted
after my comments uh
this morning about objection
and so what i'd like to wind up
with if i brought it i did uh two years
ago
i put this card together this was when i
realized
that because the media hates president
trump
they we weren't people were not aware of
what all the good things
that he did in those first couple of
years and people
were not aware of it first of all on the
card and i'm just going to run over
these
they're the biggest tax cuts and
you know we learned a lesson back there
during a
democrat administration john kennedy was
said the best way to get more revenue in
for the
for the great society programs that
where they're advocating at that time
the best way is to reduce marginal rates
and that will increase revenue it did
unfortunately john kennedy died before
he could reap the benefits
that came with that but but it worked
and and of course others followed him
including
presidents clinton president bush and
and others
by reducing the rates that also increase
uh the
revenue but what this president did that
was different than the rest of them
he not just increased or the or
decrease the rates the the tax rates but
he also decreased
all the over regulation how many people
know that back during the
obama administration we had a rule that
we're
adhering to that said if you are a
domestic oil and gas producer in the
united states of america and you're in
competition with china or somebody else
you had to give them our whole playbook
on how we put together
our our our our system over here
and all the elements put us at a
disadvantage with our competitors in
china
and that and in energy you know just
look at the
that i i was happy that i used to say
that
after obama got out of office the the uh
the the war on fossil fuels was over for
a while
and uh and look at the energy dominance
now we're the global
leader in oil and gas production a 277
growth in crude exports 132
increase in coal exports a 52 increase
in natural gas exports these are exports
that's what we're doing now
in the united states as a result of the
efforts of this president and bringing
our economy around
the crackdown on the illegal immigration
nobody wanted the wall they said now the
people realize
that's where a lot of the bad people
were getting in
uh we moved the embassy i can every
democrat and republican president in my
memory
tried to move the united states embassy
in israel to jerusalem they all talked
about they didn't do it so this
president just went ahead and did it
he enacted the infrastructure bill the
word of bill water resource
development act the faa reauthorization
and he had in the judges that we have
not just
kavanaugh and gorsuch but i think our
numbers up now to about
200 and uh 225
new judges uh he repealed the over
regulation of the dodd-frank rules
anyone in business will tell you
that that's that was one of the major
things the accomplishments of this
president president trump
the record employment that's it but then
i would say the one thing the tenth and
last one that i mentioned to everyone
who will listen is what he did for the
military
we went from the time of dropping down
in the last five years of the obama
administration by 25 percent
while china was increasing 83 percent
now so that we
are are have rebuilt that military
and that's why the ndaa is so
significant right now
to make sure that that gets passed and
that we
are able to uh
to have that and that's that's what this
vote is all about that's what the ndaa
national defense authorization act the
most important bill of the year
that's why we are doing it and that's
why we are
are that's why we're here today
during this holiday season with that uh
mr chairman i yield the floor and
suggest the absence
of a quorum clerk will call the roll
mr alexander
mr president democratic whip that is a
we're in colonel call i ask sent the
quorum call be suspended without
objection
mr president it's an unusual sighting of
a
senator in the capital between christmas
and new year's
this is one time we really try to
reserve
for our personal and family
responsibilities
our family like others looks forward to
the christmas season
it's one time a year we desperately try
to find ways to come together
of course covet 19 intervened and made
that more challenging
but even so the notion of coming back to
washington
this week and staying perhaps more than
a day
to try to finish our work is unusual and
the circumstances surrounding it are
extraordinary as well
not the least of which is the fact we
have two bills that
have to be thought of in context
of our responsibilities first and
foremost is the national defense
authorization act
this month both the house and the senate
passed with overwhelming bipartisan
majorities
the fiscal year 2021 national defense
authorization act
senator inhofe of oklahoma republican
was on the floor before me
he and senator jack reed of rhode island
put in more time than
most members can appreciate to make sure
that this bill
really served our military and the goal
of national security
they came up with a good bill one i was
proud to support
this annual legislation has been signed
into law for six
consecutive decades when the senate
fails to do
anything they always do the national
defense authorization bill
it shows that congress can come together
at least on this measure
when it comes to supporting our men and
women in uniform and keeping our country
safe
this year the bill authorizes 740.5
billion dollars in defense spending
it provides another three percent
well-deserved pay raise for our troops
it also recognizes that many in the
armed forces are
on the front lines here at home as well
helping fight the ongoing
covet 19 epidemic providing our troops
with necessary
benefits and protections including a 10
increase in hazardous duty pay the bill
also includes a number of provisions
that i authored and supported including
language expressing
strong support for the baltic states and
ukraine
especially in the face of continued
unforgivable
russian aggression it requires
the renaming of military bases in the
united states
which were once named in honor of
confederate
generals those who served in the
confederacy in an attempt to secede from
the union
and to defend the institution of slavery
have been enshrined in the names of
these bases for
many many years this effort to rename
them
is long long overdue it tries to correct
and recognize the mistakes of our past
and really address the sensitive
racial inequities at the pentagon when
it comes to this
decision-making it places restrictions
on the transfer of military equipment to
law enforcement agencies
we have to address the issue of
militarization of our police
at a time when we are frankly making an
assessment
of the role of police to make certain
that the overwhelming majority
of law enforcement officers who are good
principled
civic minded individuals are honored and
those who
fail to meet the test are removed from
service
it expands benefits to our veterans who
were exposed to agent orange during the
vietnam war there were 191 000 vietnam
era veterans in my state of illinois
many of them were exposed to toxins such
as agent orange during their service
and now are paying the price it makes it
easier for victims of military sexual
draw trauma to report instances of such
crime
and expand support for survivors the
most recent
horrible incident at fort hood was a
reminder
of what we need to do to bring the
military into the 21st century
when it comes to respecting the rights
of all people men and women
it strengthens safeguards against
foreign cyber attacks
we know how important that is after the
recent revelation
confirmed by secretary of state pompeo
that russia is at work again
attempting to compromise our federal
agencies
their data their information and the
security secrets that they keep
for our protection it authorizes funding
for pfas related research
if you've never heard the phrase pfas
before i can tell you you're bound to
hear it in the future
this was used as a flame retardant
in in some other capacities
on many air force bases and military
bases around the united states
we're finding it's still there and it's
still dangerous
we need to put money into remediation to
help these military installations
including scott air force base in
belleville illinois where pfas was
detected earlier this year
still despite all the good things in
this bill the bipartisanship that
supported it
president trump decided to veto the bill
one of his rare vetoes
he prefers we continue to honor the
confederate leaders
who committed treasonous atrocities in
order to
preserve slavery i don't think that is
reflective of the united states of today
or its values
but that's his position and when he was
called out
for this racist inclination he changed
the reasoning for his veto
he claims the bill didn't do enough to
fight china or that we should include a
measure to address
liability issues for tech companies
never mind the
tech company liability matters have
nothing to do with the national defense
authorization act he just doesn't like
that that there's criticism coming down
for some of the misstatements and lies
and disinformation he's been spreading
on social media the president also fails
to recognize this defense authorization
bill in fact
does get tough on china creates a new
pacific deterrence initiative
that puts america back in the seat of
leadership in that region
where we need to be the trump
administration
could have started this initiative on
its own they did not
so congress stepped up and created this
security partnership
because the white house was asleep at
the wheel
at the end of the day i suppose we can't
expect anything more from a president
who has denigrated their troops by
calling them suckers and losers
i voted to support the fiscal year 21
ndaa i'll support it again to override
this president's
unforgivable and reckless veto i'm glad
the house did so
on monday i hope we in the senate do the
same
coming back to washington was not
something i looked forward to this week
i wanted to stay home
but i knew when it came to funding our
troops i had to be here
many other my colleagues feel the same i
hope tomorrow we can take that up
quickly
then there was the drama around the
coven 19 relief bill
it was hard to describe what we went
through in the last week to 10 days
with messages from the white house
i wish that the president and those
around him advising him
would have called to mind the 335 000
americans who've lost their lives
due to this deadly pandemic and many
more who've lost a family member a
friend or a loved one
in illinois we've lost 16 thousand lives
to covent 19.
tragic historic i extend my deepest
condolences to the friends and families
of those who've died
or are fighting this virus many are my
friends
more than 121 thousand americans spent
last night in a hospital
a grim new record of hospitalization as
our heroic nurses and doctors face
unrelenting stress from this crisis
i just think as i reflect on the
interviews
with these men and women who are on the
front line of health care
how stoic they usually are how
controlled they usually are
and how they're losing it now the
overwhelming numbers that they're facing
the terrible prospect of someone dying
with a member of their family unable to
even enter the room
on the last minutes of their life has
got to be heartbreaking on a scale that
none of us can imagine
but think about doing that every single
day
they've done it and i tell you we will
never be able to repay them with our
gratitude they are true american heroes
many of us returned to washington this
week as i said
celebrating the holidays in a fashion
like never before
social distancing zooms face time calls
with family and loved ones
it's no substitute for the kids being
there to open the gifts on christmas
morning
but it's the reality of what we face
today there is some hope on the horizon
and though i've been critical many times
of the trump administration
i do want to give the president credit
for the warp speed program
it is amazing as i read the stories of
what they were able to achieve
in discovering not more than one i hope
and more than two
vaccines that can treat americans and
people around the world keep them safe
as they face this coronavirus we broke
all the records
in the discovery of these vaccines and i
as i read about it i am continue to be
grateful and want to make sure america
recognizes
the doctors the scientists the
researchers
barney graham i didn't know his name
until yesterday and it came out in a
story published in new yorker
he works at the national institute of
health he's given a great deal of credit
for the breakthrough in the first two
vaccines that have been approved
and others just like him i want to
salute dr francis collins
at the national institutes of health dr
anthony fauci both of whom
have become my friends over the years
and what a job they've done for america
so many more deserve recognition and i
hope there will be an opportunity to
give it to them
but the fact is these doses of vaccines
are starting to move across the country
last week illinois i'm proud to say led
the nation i congratulated our governor
jb pritzker yesterday
more than a hundred thousand health care
workers received their first shots last
week i asked him why we led and he said
i don't know
we just put together our own program of
distribution and it worked
thank goodness it did lives will be
saved because of it but there's so much
more to do
progress in administering the vaccine
has been slow as we still struggle to
reach the hardest hit areas
and the rosy projections from the
administration have not come to fruition
yet
but the fact is we have two viable
vaccines
that is miraculous i look forward to the
new administration the biden
administration's new management of this
effort
and i'm glad congress came together to
pass a relief bill
which included 30 billion dollars for
vaccine development and distribution
when the president said he wasn't going
to sign this bill i thought how can he
say that
he should be taking credit rightfully
for the warp speed program and his
role in seeing that program move forward
instead of complicating the distribution
of the vaccine by threatening to veto
the bill
fortunately for us in the end he signed
the bill
on sunday evening the president signed
the bipartisan annual spending bill
and the coven 19 relief bill there were
complaints about the size of the bill
while the entire
federal budget was included in that bill
as well as the covet 19
relief undertaking as well as many other
bills such as the water resources
development act
all of these are major pieces of
legislation
they were combined in one bill that went
way beyond five
thousand pages unfortunately the
president delayed
in signing the bill and created needless
uncertainty in america
particularly among the unemployed and
others who were suffering from this
public health and economic crisis
this agreement provides much needed
support for many of them
and they'll have some delay in receiving
their checks because of the president's
period of indecision
enhanced unemployment benefits at 300 a
week and an extension of the
unemployment program created under the
cares act
through march 14th will bring real
relief to many
millions of families 325 billion
possibly the largest single item in the
covent relief bill
went to provide our nation's ailing
small businesses
another chance at survival the paycheck
protection program
worked in the initial cares act it was
renewed in this undertaking
an extension the federal eviction
moratorium through january
2021 coupled with 25 billion dollars an
emerging
emergency rental system will literally
mean that people are not evicted
right after christus christmas
approximately 850 millions going to
illinois
to help keep families in their homes
during this pandemic
the 15 increase in nutrition assistance
is certainly needed
it goes through the snap program which
was historically known as food stamps to
make sure that families do have
something on the table
i can tell you i woke up this morning in
springfield illinois
to look at the front page newspaper to
learn that an anonymous donor had given
our local food bank
five hundred thousand dollars and the
people of the food bank were of course
appreciative and said they desperately
needed it in my hometown and in towns
all across america so this increase in
food stamp
assistance is long overdue and i'm glad
was included
the bill included a number of important
measures but we have to go to work
to make sure that we deal with a
short-term
emergency response to this bill but do
more
we address the needs to meet to meet the
needs of the
pandemic immediately but more will
follow it was a tough negotiation and
honest compromise i was happy to be part
of a bipartisan group of senators
who may have got the ball rolling at
least we think we did and handed it over
to the leaders to finish the job
i think what we achieved on a bipartisan
basis was largely included
in the final bill and it addressed the
major elements that were necessary
one of the most important items that
congress failed to reach an agreement on
was funding for state and local
governments
states and localities are struggling
with increased costs and decreased
revenues due to the pandemic
by this summer my home state of illinois
will have lost more than 5 billion
in revenues i can tell you that that's
going to cause
pain and cut backs this is not
money that was lost in our pension
system which has its own share of
troubles
but money that is directly attributable
to the downturn in revenues
because the covet 19 pandemic it isn't
just happening in illinois it's
happening all around the country
in red and blue states our neighboring
state of kentucky to the south of us
facing the same hardships we are federal
funding for states and localities
needs to be done for our great cities
and great states
that are struggling and i certainly hope
that the next president when he's sworn
in january 20th
will take this up as one of his highest
priorities our
nation's economic recovery is slowed
down by budget cuts that will be
necessary in states and localities
because of this cutback of revenues now
the
most widely discussed measure of the
cova 19 relief bill
was the second round of economic impact
payments
just yesterday the house of
representatives passed the cash act
a measure that would increase the direct
payments to individuals
adults and children from six hundred
dollars to two thousand dollars
for those who are earning less than
seventy five thousand dollars a year
the measure passed in the house by a
vote of 275 to 174.
over the past several months we've heard
time and again
from economists that we run the risk of
doing too little
and that far outweighs the risk of doing
too much when it comes to this economic
recovery
the head of the federal reserve chairman
powell has
really instructed us to keep the foot on
the accelerator so that our economy
economy doesn't slump into a recession
in a time when so many american families
are laid off
unemployed and simply struggling to get
by there is nothing more invigorating to
the economy than to have a cash infusion
those with limited resources battling to
pay bills
turn around and spend that money quickly
they don't solve it away for some
future rainy day they need it now and
that's why we should seriously consider
this
by passing this enhanced measure we
could restore the american public
confidence in washington
and the fact that we are listening and
working together on a bipartisan basis
to respond this measure
that passed the house of representatives
has the support of the president
speaker pelosi house democrats as well
as many
house republicans leader schumer and my
senate democratic colleagues support it
so i hope senator mcconnell the
republican leader
and his colleagues in the republican
caucus will join us and allow us to pass
this bill
quickly this week let's step up to the
plate and get this done
the american people have waited too long
for for this relief
i for one am proud of my colleagues on
both sides of the aisle for coming
together and passing
a meaningful relief bill but the time
for petting one another on the back is
over
let's finish a job let's make sure that
we have this authorization bill for the
department of defense
and that we come to the rescue of our
families across america
who need defense against the vagaries of
this pandemic and this economy
we can finally see a slight glimmer of a
light at the end of this tunnel
if we want to address address the needs
of americans in crisis
it starts with passing this legislation
mr president i yield the floor
suggests the absence of court clerk will
call the roll mr alexander
mr frozen the senate majority leader is
recognized
i asked consent that further proceeds on
the quorum call of the defense
without objection so mr president for
the information of all senators
we'll have a live quorum call at 5 pm
tomorrow
followed immediately by a roll call vote
on proceeding to the veto message
on the ndaa so senators
should be on the floor at that time
again that's 5 00
p.m tomorrow i understand there are two
bills at the desk and i asked for their
first reading and block
the clerk will read the title of the
bills for the first time
s-5085 a bill to amend the internal
revenue code of 1986 to increase
the additional 2020 recovery rebates and
so forth and further purposes
h.r 9051 an act to amend the internal
revenue code of 1986 to increase
recovery rebate amounts
and so forth and for other purposes
i now ask for a second reading and i
object to my own request all in block
objection having been heard the bills
receive their second reading
on the next legislative day
as united stand when the senate
completes his business today
it adjourn until 3 p.m wednesday
december 30th
further that fall in the prayer and
pledge the morning hour be deemed
expired the journal of proceedings be
approved to date
the time for the two leaders to be
reserved for the use later in the day
finally fought in leader remarks senate
being a period of morning business with
senators permission to speak there in
front of 10 minutes each
without objection so if there's no
further business come before the senate
i stand adjourned
under the previous order
senate stands adjourned until 3 pm
tomorrow
you